could you talk about the tone that you
go for and how you establish this kind
of reality that's also I think they were
definitely laughs throughout it and
there's also there wasn't a sound being
made at the end so you know I like
telling stories in a way that the
characters are going to be a bit of a
mystery that on falls for us I like it
when I go to a movie and I lean towards
the movie right and we're leaning
towards me and and so that was part of
the approach here you know I I told
Salman you have all these qualities
she's the treats the only difference is
she's funny but other than that is like
she's Beatrice and and and I just wanted
to encourage her I we feel and all of
this just let it because we're going to
move towards you and she was very brave
and and like really got that and just
just was there it's just present every
take was different even in the subtle of
the way she was used letters no be
present which I think makes it so that
we want to go along an attorney with her
but that's the kind of movies I like
tonight George of course is that other
tell you a little example of how we work
when we were working together
how specific me get it was because it
was so shocking for me he did not want
to know what I was thinking okay I was
not allowed to move my face or cry and
so or my body and so I remember there
was one one take one time we said no got
caught and I turn around he goes I knew
exactly what you were thinking exactly I
could read the thought in you said no
you didn't move your face but your eyes
were too specific exactly and so I know
I said okay okay and I was tired I was
very late that night and it was cold and
I said okay action cut what now you're
not thinking of anything it's true but
it's true but it it's profound because
if you predetermine what you're thinking
like if you get tired and you just know
what you would think if somebody said or
did something and even if you don't move
the face it doesn't have the same
complexity or depth that if you're
completely present and just hearing it
for the first that night I got tired it
was like the third for take and then I
just automatically was trying to think I
was thinking what I thought the time
before and this was not possible under
she's loop he's that brilliant I don't
know anybody else and it is in the
little monitor so I thought everybody
was going to be so bored with me doing
nothing because my face was not going to
change never and the camera was here I
didn't care that I'm sorry I didn't care
if you were bored I was in this van I
working with this director so happy and
then when I saw the movie I'm not only
my face but my face it's transformed
grotesque is in so many different ways
and this is all that's only legal did
you have any discussions about
likability of the characters or was
there anybody who was nervous about what
was being said in in this piece as far
as they were concerned it was everybody
just kind of willing to let it be
honestly I've been waiting to work with
me here for a long time
I can understand why and we tried before
and then that movie didn't happen and I
have so much respect
Mike this one was for me I've been
waiting for this movie for so long
and it came to me at 49 and we were
shooting the day of my birthday so I
didn't care if anybody like me or not I
mean I and I'll probably never get
another piece so for me I was I thought
it was not gonna happen the only time it
happened before really was when I had to
do it for myself took me eight years to
get Frieda off the ground so I was so
used to struggling after strolling
thirty years of a career hey give me a
shot scandalous try me out you know
after begging for 30 years
two of my greatest heroes with I think
they are two of the most talented people
in the United States as filmmakers I
really do
all of a sudden show up in my house and
they just like give it to me I want
honestly when we talked about he told me
I have this idea for a movie you know we
want you to be in it and I'm like oh
that's great I said well what it's about
it's a dinner great and it's a dinner Oh
fantastic and I'm thinking in my head
for sure I played it the ditches they
cook maybe I am serving the dinner I
don't care even if it's you know two
things one scene and be so happy to work
with him and then I said what do I play
and he said a masseuse I'm like okay
more practice I try to get more
information you would say nothing at
some point doors any said okay I'll give
you another thing uh-huh there's a goat
so I didn't I was not trying to to see
if they were gonna like me if they were
I mean it was so reach all the
conversations Miguel and I had beautiful
conversations for a week before a lot
longer but we would drive further than
her zones it was an hour he would write
even flower to take me and we would
drive by the ocean and just had the most
amazing conversations maybe by there was
nothing to do with we had trees we would
get me it would sense sense civilize me
you know will get me in the mood I
wanted to do so good for them you know
because they believed in me I didn't
want to support I wanted to just do my
best so I didn't care I didn't I didn't
even ask a lot of questions about these
or that once we started shooting I'm
just well it's a beautiful beautiful
film I thank you for taking some time to
talk with us